[Music]
it's again time for keynotech news in
the past few days news about the leaked
footage of the Five Nights at Freddy's
movie Beetlejuice 2 and a new character
in James Gunn Superman Legacy made
headlines in addition the first trailer
from Meg 2 the trench with Jason Statham
will Delight fans of popcorn movies and
last but not least the writers strike in
Hollywood is still keeping the film and
series World in suspense some very
popular projects have now been put on
hold
big bigger Meg the new trailer for Meg 2
the trench has taken the Internet by
storm and raised anticipation to a new
level the trailer promises a more than
entertaining film that is in no way
inferior to its predecessor when Meg hit
theaters in 2018 no one expected the
film to become such a hit it's about a
team of explorers fighting the biggest
shark of all time the Megalodon the film
was directed by John turtletop and
featured Jason Statham in the lead role
thus the first images of the sequel Meg
2 which is this time directed by Ben
Wheatley were awaited with great
excitement on Monday the first trailer
was finally released worldwide it starts
off in an unusual manner sets 65 million
years in the past true to the motto
there's always a bigger fish various
prehistoric creatures eat each other
until finally a huge T-Rex is devoured
by the Megalodon no doubt an
announcement with a wink towards the
Jurassic world franchise then there's a
Time jump Jason Statham must get back to
work his character is asked for help as
there is unusual activity deep in the
sea and whatever is down there it wants
to come to the surface a first Excursion
in mechanical diving suits directly
leads to a disaster needless to say
there are huge monsters lurking in the
depths and of course they are now making
their way to civilization lizard
creatures are attacked with shovels
helicopters are pulled into the sea by
giant octopuses and several victims are
eaten by a whole swarm of Megs meanwhile
Jason Statham fights a Megalodon on a
jet ski with a sword Meg 2 obviously
aims to be a true popcorn movie and fans
are thrilled even though some complain
that the whole project is going down too
much of a trash route another box office
success seems to be as good as certain
however whether Meg II the trench can
compete with its predecessor is
something we'll see in theaters starting
August 4th 2023.
the Superman matter was certainly one of
the most discussed points at the
refounding of DC Studios at the end of
2022 after much initially indicated that
Henry Cavill would return to his iconic
role as Clark Kent the decision was
ultimately made not to continue the
movie series with Cavill however it
became clear quite quickly that this by
no means means a farewell to the
character because we can look forward to
Superman Legacy directed by James Gunn
himself rumors recently circulated that
a somewhat unusual character will
celebrate his DC live-action movie debut
in it the talk is of crypto Superman's
four-legged friend as Chris Pratt and
James Gunn confirmed in an interview
with the Toronto Sun the super dog who
made his debut in the Adventure Comics
in 1955 will feature in Superman Legacy
the two seem to be in a good mood and
joked about how Pratt could then be paid
in cryptocurrency so by all indications
the appearance of crypto is not only a
rumor despite the humorous interview the
confirmed that it was indeed an
exclusive announcement crypto previously
appeared for example in DC League of
Super Pets or in the Animated Series
crypto the Superdog from the 2000s and
like his master possesses superpowers he
also comes from the Planet Krypton and
can for instance fire heat Rays from his
eyes and has an intelligence similar to
that of a human being as seen in DC
League of Super Pets he can even absorb
solar energy and attack his opponents
with a solar-powered posturing we can
thus look forward to some funny moments
with crypto the reactions so far have
been very positive many are looking
forward to crypto's live-action debut
and the resulting alignment with the
comics where he has played a much bigger
role up to now who wouldn't want to see
Superman's laser beam shooting pet in
action in a live-action film Superman
Legacy is set to arrive in theaters on
July 11 2025.
the hype surrounding the upcoming film
adaptation of the video game Five Nights
at Freddy's is huge since the release of
the first part in 2014 a huge fan base
has formed which will probably make up a
large part of the future moviegoers
after a leak about the still work in
progress movie made the rounds last week
game creator Scott cawthon expressed
great frustration regarding the
circumstances but he was pleasantly
surprised by a number of fans last
weekend an unknown user published a very
early version of the trailer for The
Five Nights at Freddy's movie on Twitter
Not only was the footage obviously taken
from the midst of the production process
and therefore not intended for the
public but it was also filmed from a
cell phone in poor quality all this
contributed to creating a bad impression
of the project the creator of the game
series Scott cawthon initially tried to
ignore the numerous reports on various
news portals and social media but then
couldn't help but comment on the
unfortunately on Reddit cotton expressed
his utter dejection and disappointment
over the fact that the first visual
impression of the project was so
negative after all he and his team had
worked very hard to create something
exciting nevertheless he was pleased to
see that many fans took to YouTube and
Twitter to speak out against the leaf
and unite him in support of the project
many didn't watch the leaked video While
others refrained from showing it in
their coverage and thus contributed to
the fact that probably only a small part
of the Five Nights at Freddy's fan
Community ruined their first impression
we are excited to learn when the
finished trailer will officially come
out and look forward to the theatrical
release on October 27 2023
the horror comedy Beetlejuice hit the
big screen almost 35 years ago among
fans the project is one of the absolute
Classics of the 1980s as it was revealed
this week there is some new information
about a sequel the film could follow in
the footsteps of Ghostbusters afterlife
which likewise offered an excellent mix
of 80s Nostalgia with old and new actors
as well as modern elements with the
announcement that Batman actor Michael
Keaton will in fact return once again to
the role of the eponymous ghost it seems
they want to pick up both old and new
audiences when asked by some fans
whether Keaton at 71 was not too old for
the role film composer Danny Elfman
humorously replied that the makeup
already made Beetlejuice look as if he
were 150 years old in the first part
accordingly Keaton's return would not be
an issue stranger things starve Winona
Ryder is also back and will once again
play the part of Lydia Dietz the role of
her daughter will also be cast
prominently with Wednesday actress Jenna
Ortega taking on the role Justin Paul
Thoreau who last played a part in the
horror flick false positive in 2021 is
also set to take on an undisclosed role
the shooting of Beetlejuice 2 is already
starting this week under the resumed
direction of horror icon Tim Burton in
London Burton also has the support of
his favorite composer Danny elthman who
was already involved in part one the
planned us release is scheduled for
September 6 2024 according to deadline
we'll keep you posted on any further
updates
the large-scale strike of the writer
skilled of America began on May 2nd 2023
the union represents many writers in the
U.S film and TV industry which is why
the effects of the current strike are
being felt in many ways we will now
inform you about the current state of
affairs and the impacted films and
Series in addition to demands from
authors for higher wages as well as
better job security the so-called
writer's room is to be given more
freedom this is the place where authors
write the scripts and are creative while
this used to actually be a physical
location controlled by the showrunner
the creative process in today's
screenwriting often takes place in the
home office film studios ought to hire
more writers and thus facilitate the
creative process at present too few
writers are being hired for a project
who are then constantly overworked a
further demand of the wga concerns the
use of artificial intelligence in the
creation of scripts many fear that in a
few years the technology will be so
Advanced that it will lead to a rapidly
dwindling need for human writers which
would make many authors unemploy void
within a very short time so there's a
lot at stake for the Striking writers
who have been in negotiations with the
producers about future working
conditions since mid-march so far there
has been a lot of support from the
actors with many showing solidarity with
the strikers moreover some actors are
affected by the repercussions themselves
which is why they are also likely to
have a great interest in seeing the
strike brought to an end as quickly as
possible the concrete impact on series
and films has been severe so far one of
the most prominent examples is season 5
of stranger things which cannot be shot
as planned meaning that the show's
launch will be postponed Blade with
green book star mahershava Ali will also
likely be unable to begin filming next
month as scheduled which means even the
MCU is officially hit by the strength
additionally Game of Thrones author
George R.R Martin commented on the
upcoming spin-off a night of the Seven
Kingdoms the Hedge Knight in a blog post
Martin explained that the project will
have to be put on hold for the time
being however he added that the filming
of the second season of House of the
Dragon is not affected and will continue
other projects concerned and thus on
Hiatus are Cobra Kai season 6
Yellowjackets season 3 Big Mouth season
8 and Lord of the Rings the rings of
power season 2. also halted are
Productions of the handmaid's tale HBO's
hacks and Abbott Elementary various talk
shows and late night formats were also
among the quickest to be adversely
affected since the strike began Saturday
Night Live has been playing only reruns
and there's been none of the usual
nonchalance on Jimmy Kim alive or The
Late Show with Stephen Colbert either in
the last show before the strike Colbert
already talked about the negotiations
between the wga and the amptp and
expressed his solidarity with the
writers without whom the show would not
be as successful as it is today at
present it is not apparent when the
parties will reach an agreement the
Striker's concerns have at least made it
to the Oval Office so far since on
Monday U.S President Joe Biden also
commented on the current events and
hoped that the authors would emerge from
the talks with a fair deal as you can
see the situation is anything but
Pleasant for all parties involved and it
can only be hoped that the authors will
quickly come to an understanding with
the producers otherwise it's safe to
assume that even more movies in series
will be among those affected we will
keep you up to date on further
developments
that was the news for this week don't
forget to check out the new trailers
such as Oppenheimer here on our Channel
we also have an original episode on
Gladiator 2 for all fans of historical
films other than that we hope you
enjoyed this week's news feel free to
give the video a thumbs up thanks for
watching and we'll see you next time
[Music]
oh